in great defensive formation and okay
ding decides
he can go for it he's gone with a nice
sacrifice
offering up that night if it's captured
now okay magnus ignoring that night if
it was captured then the black bishop
would have
come into come to life it would have
taken the pawn pinning the white rook
and coming towards the white king
magnus ignoring the black knight which
is actually pinned and he just brings
his knight forward
attacking black's bishop and also
defending one of white's pawns in the
center we're gonna see a result here
because uh
magnus has just refuted ding's attempt
at an attack and you can see ding is
absolutely upset with himself he's
shaking his head
he did not see this move i mean what a
fantastic response from magnus because
like you said
the black knight cannot move and also
the white knight is
threatening to jump into the position
and
fork the rook and the queen um
is there there's a check right what
happens if black plays
knight just for just for pity sake
okay so yeah too many threats in the
position yeah
uh yeah i really don't see anything for
doing right now no i don't see anything
either
he looks like he's just giving up here
yeah he just looks absolutely despondent
and uh
and i bet you he's thinking about
yesterday's moment because he
he made so close yeah it was like a
butterfly effect type of move he made
one little rook check and that work
check
had catastrophic consequences because it
meant that he
pushed the white king forward and okay
we see a check
on the board and after bishop takes
knight queen
takes bishop knight takes bishop and now
the big threat unfortunately is queen
takes pawn check
and that is going to be game over
nothing to do about that so uh ding
losing material i mean is there any hope
i have to i have to mention as well i
mean for dingli ren this is the first
time he reached the knockout phase
because we know he's been playing in the
middle of the night in china in the
other tournaments and he is
uh before this tournament in 19th place
on the tour standings so he's fighting
desperately to
get those chore points to qualify for
the big finals well and i bet
um a third place and a fourth place here
he gives up the
first game is a big difference for him
in in terms of
tour points yeah